Birmingham has set itself up as a city
that's serious about tackling climate
change
it's ideas are bold and the plan is to
ban cars from the city center altogether
but coronavirus has turned aspirations
over emissions upside down and business
leaders admit staying loyal to green
ambitions won't be easy whilst getting
the economy back on its feet right now
businesses are hemorrhaging cash we're
seeing that no business is trying to to
stay alive and so while certainly you
know we know that there has been a lot
of good intent to go green from a
business perspective sitting over the
last sort of 1224 four months I think
just the sort of financial flexibility
and probably the almost the the mental
capacity to do that while you're just
trying to keep your business alive or
sort of in survival mode is going to
make that more challenging
Trainz skies and roads this busy seemed
like a long time ago but Sky News has
seen data which shows just how much of a
short-term impact staying at home has
had on our carbon intensive lifestyles
as expected carbon emissions have
decreased in recent weeks but we now
know they've gone down more than a third
every day since the start of lockdown
there's been a 60% reduction in the use
of passenger vehicles Road Transport was
the biggest source of carbon emissions
in the UK and there's been a 20 percent
increase in residential emissions with
more people working from home just a few
months ago there was a real momentum in
tackling climate change the committee
which advises the government on how to
reach its goal to make Britain carbon
neutral by 2050 is now trying to get
that momentum back in a letter to the
government the Committee on climate
change has set out a number of economic
goals which include making green
investments to support economic recovery
limiting financial support for sectors
which are carbon intensive and
supporting working from home and the
low-carbon lifestyles that we've learned
under lockdown happily the things that
we can do to invest in climate change
and improve the problems of climate
change here in the UK are also things
that we can do to help recover well from
from what is that going to be a very
damaging I suspect economic crisis post
covered and I think we need to bring
those two things together in reality the
short term reductions in emissions won't
have any significant impact on reaching
long-term climate goals but coronavirus
has shown how easily habits can change
Lisa Holland Sky News Birmingham